[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans coming at you
from bear burger and greenwich village
where i'm joined by the internet's
busiest music nerd anthony fantano
you know anthony from his youtube
channel the needle drop where he
delivers music reviews daily to the
masses
i have a lot of strong opinions on music
and i've delivered some opinions on
opinions
over the years as well but today two of
the most prolific bald men on youtube
are joining forces
to review some of the most buzzed about
meatless creations
in new york city now anthony you've been
a
thick vegan now for what about 10 years
right i mean i've been a vegan for about
10 years but i've been a thick vegan
probably for a shorter amount of time
as somebody who exists on youtube i
don't think that youtube
is a great welcoming space for
anything for anything really but
especially vegans
can you talk about existing in that
place you know youtube is
pretty much the place where you have an
ugly an ugly debate about anything you
give up a video of a cute animal
and instantaneously comments saying oh
that that dog's gay or something you
know and don't expect a
sane conversation about anything in the
comments that's kind of what i've
learned
now is a good time to be vegan you have
this mass availability
you have food that is actually really
good
you're going to be reviewing these foods
from that vegan experience
what i'm going to be doing is somebody
who eats chicken wings for a living
is coming at it from that perspective we
will do it out of 10
keep it very needle drop today anthony
ready to get it going yes
so this first one is the barbecue seitan
sandwich from monk's meat in brooklyn
new york
it's a seitan caramelized onions mustard
coleslaw vegan mayo and whiskey
sour pickles the creators treat their
barbecue satan like real barbecue pork
dry rubbing it and smoking it low and
slow certainly looks like a
barbecue pork because they're really
colorful
on you know just a barbecue level
it does mimic the taste of meat pretty
well i haven't had meat in a while so i
have to take my word for it i'll take
your word for it even though it's
probably not very
likely that i'd be interested in me ever
again this makes the likelihood way
lower
the smokiness of the sauce and just kind
of like the chewiness of the seitan
and the crunchy vegetables on it too and
the
pickles just being as sour as they are
it's just like so many different layers
to it it's really good
what are you giving it out of ten i
would i would say a light eight say a
light eight
honestly let's see a light eight i see
it
i see it as a light seven if i'm just
trying this
i wouldn't be able to tell that it's not
me
up next we have the spicy marquez
sandwich from butcher's daughter on the
lower east side
the white bean vegan sausage with a fig
mostarda so this particular sausage is
based off a lamb made with a variety of
spices
the marquez has a little bit of a spicy
kick to it
not gonna blow you away hot but a little
bit of a kick
the spice blend is very herby it's very
earthy kind of quality to it in
comparison to the sandwich we just ate
it's a little lighter on the palate if
you want something that tastes like a
big
fat american sausage sandwich this is
not it it's a nice
nice little light this is like a
downtown new york hey let's go get a
sausage sandwich
you know like at the italian place
around the corner this is like very much
like a
little a little bistro on the corner
you're eating outside
and you're reading the newspaper and a
bunch of jag officer walking by
what are you giving it out of 10 i would
i would give this one like a light seven
a light seven seven vegan meat
substitute to vegan meat substitute
i prefer the barbecue that we had in the
previous sandwich to the sausage in this
sandwich but
as a whole thing that comes together i
do prefer
the spicy marquez to the barbecue
sandwich i'm giving this one
a 7 out of 10. all right so up next is
the new
creation from superiority burger in the
east village
it's a vegan roll made with yuba
caramelized
onions pickles vegan dijon vinaigrette
and the steak in this is actually
soy milk that's heated and then they
take the skim that's on top
they take that off and that's what's
thrown on the grill here to make
the sort of meat substitute
so it's strange it's so thinly sliced
like maybe uh thinly sliced roast beef
but it doesn't taste like roast beef
it don't chew like roast beef either you
know it's been a while since i've had
any meat meeting i don't think anything
in the meat world has ever chewed quite
like this you know when you're rating an
album you always have to contextualize
an album sure before you give it a
number right
what's the intent what are you giving it
out ten i'm feeling kind of like a
decent a strong four on it
as long as we're making music
comparisons over here yes you know i
mean this could very much be the demo
album
you know what i mean like i think
there's like potential to what's
happening here
i'm gonna give it a decent to strong six
i actually didn't mind it it felt like a
little bit of a thinly sliced
deli meat to me they're not trying to
make a meat substitute
they call it the new creation and it is
very much
a new creation so these were all
appetizers anthony we've just been
getting our feet
wet now it's the moment that everyone's
been waiting for it's time
for the impossible burger
[Music]
this is supposed to be as close to the
real thing
as anyone has ever come let me hit you
with the specs you have
wheat proteins for fleshy texture potato
proteins for crispy exterior
japanese yams and xanthan gum to hold
the ingredients together
it's coconut oil with a dash of soy
beans to make it sizzle
this burger actually bleeds thanks
to a special ingredient called heme heme
is found in every living being it's what
makes your blood cells
red it carries oxygen in our comment
section we have the most
impassioned raw meat police on the
internet
they are going to flip [ __ ] about this
being raw
mentally it's like a little bit of
psyching me out i'm scared to eat it i
mean
whatever i'll just take a bite of it and
see how it goes down
[Music]
it's really weird actually it's like
kind of freaking me out like in
unbreakable and you're bruce willis and
you touch someone's hand and then all of
a sudden
like you've seen all the bad things that
they do
i've just bitten this burger and it's
like i remember every burger that i ever
ate
it tastes like a dry aged high-end
burger to me
like a medium rare burger pretty much
exactly
not only is it visually like a bit of a
mind [ __ ] it has a very meaty
kind of quality to it to the way that
shoes to the way that it smells
to just the aromas in your nose when
you're chewing so you know if they're
if their goal here is to recreate that
experience
you know they've done it kind of
perfectly i could give this a 10 in
terms of just
the recreation you know because it was
literally so close that i was like
whoa to me it's a very strong nine
bordering on light 10. and i came in
here as a bit of a skeptic
you know i'm a little bit of a burger
snob so i'm like it's not gonna have
that exact sort of burger quality
i don't care how many people write about
it and say that it does you can't fool
sean evans but in this one
i'm an idiot i'm blindfolded i can't
tell the difference at all this looks
and tastes and smells like you know
exactly what i shouldn't be [ __ ]
eating
this is very much what it claims to be
the realest fakest burger in the world
[Music]
subscribe to the needle drop first we
feast you already know
until next time internet i'm sean evans